So the first game for today Dragon HG
from Puerto Rico,
well, yes, has now accepted the pawn here
on
C4, which is often a real
sacrifice Bishop F5 is a bit
unusual now in the combination
also has the knight
down, well, well  But the
first
question is how we
might get the pawn back or how
exactly we want to sacrifice it so that
C2 falls out.
Well, I'll try knight
A3 to get the pawn back. It
actually covers it, which of course
always happens a bit  It's wobbly because
the bishop here is standing so strangely, so it's
unusually positioned, so I could now,
for example, if I were to take knight H4 straight away,
he can still move the knight
B3 yes, it's a real
sacrifice, it always plays on the strange
pawn constellation here, which is weak,
so now you have to think about
whether you can somehow do something direct.
Knight H4 went and bishop
E4, well, he should be in the right position for the time being,
ah, he loses even more
But time would like to bring the bishop to D5,
yes I'll put the 3 on bishop D5,
I'll just go to
C2 with the idea of ​​E4 and
catch the bishop so he attacks A3 in return,
yes interesting
position could still
play E4 and then let him take it
and say I'll open the position here
and that should be good for me t well
difficult
a moment,
what happens if I
hit B? Runner F3 the problem is
probably runner F3 Runner
F3 yes, I definitely have
a lot of time away again  Now let's do
E4, it's definitely an interesting
position on bishop A3. I'm going to
first do bishop
F6, I get that
back and now it's interesting which
move he wants to play now,
yes now I have rook E1 check
also
no
yes
so yes good okay  now of course
I have compensation here for the
material question now just how to
continue correctly Knight D4 maybe with the
idea Knight F5 or Knight simply
yes that's a good move I think so
the idea is now under either
Knight F5 that  is a nice field
Knight C6 sometimes very easy or
even runner D5 can also be an idea
so bishop D5 CD Queen C8 King G7
Queen G4 and so on or knight F5
then knight F5 exactly the same way
now you can definitely just
jump  Play C6 which
is definitely not bad he
can't move the queen because of
knight
B4 if he takes dam C6 bishop
E1 here check king G7 yes I get
something back
no that's the question in fact the
question maybe you also have
one  A better move is
certainly possible Knight F5 Bishop E1 dam
C5 yes, I have to go a little bit
faster, this is the
simple continuation here, but it's definitely
okay,
okay, he moves the way, which
I find surprising, I thought he would really like to move in now
exchange a little something like Queen F6 player bishop C3
or
something like that then s
chess
so
I now have more than
permanent chess yes I have so little time
I definitely have more than permanent chess
but I don't see
how yet I play to win
because of the
time you have  Of course I can understand
the pure position is certainly good
for
white
yes, of course it's here again now
the time is the problem black stands
here like an absolute
garbage man
totally totally in the bucket for
black yes and now the smartmve
super yes nice introduction for today
easy  I was too slow. Position was
of course excellent. It only costs
four points because it was provisional. Yes, of
course I have a priority
attacking position. It's probably
just really
good. Yes, I could play D4 here
Okay, let's do the remie first,
but yes the computer suggests tower E5,
I've also seen that but well,
the time is of course somehow
a
problem H6 tur F5 it gives me, only
no, yes well, I only have 35
seconds left
No, well, it was interesting